thank you
foreign
[Music]
we live Shawty
what's goody hot press verse
we getting we're getting some technical
spectacle
worked out
but we wind up
get on here live
we live shouty
we live shroudy
we lie challenge
we live Shawty
you're live shouting shouty
[Music]
we we live Shawty oh we got moody in
here
what's goody Moody
oh there goes my camera hold on there we
go
well we get Yoshi cooking
posted a video about uh performing at a
college
here in America
oh that's
I wonder how he booked that I'm trying
to book colleges
they're stealing our job Joe [__]
[Music]
come back okay Bet
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey what's up
Mary
Lance
angels on y'all that's goody what's
goodies
say in the building Lance
Joe quihotek
good seeing you fam
good good
good good good good good good good good
good
seeing your fans
hey
good seeing you fam
this is the joke feedback hour
what's up John what's up Jerry
okay good Moody laughed at that so we're
safe y'all
he laughed
how's y'all's Tuesday going out there
y'all
how y'all doing out there
I think Yoshi's trying a new camera
[Music]
is what the Disney is
a
there we go
let me turn that down a little bit mudit
how did you book that college man that's
really cool
hilarious Jerry just said take the cover
off the lens
he he went out and he's going to come
back in he said
whoa
mind Focus
foreign
this is the joke feedback hour fan we
about to be giving y'all some joke
feedback hope y'all are having a good
week out there
ah
foreign
Focus Adderall very funny Joe
very funny
so if y'all do have jokes you'd like
some feedback on go ahead and post them
in the live chat and we will definitely
get to those
[Music]
cool beans
foreign
reached out to an independent producer
whose weekly bar show happens to be at a
bar
that's a part of the campus oh nice
oh very cool
you get it how you can get it you know
that's for sure
all right let me pull this up
hey
there we go okay
we're cooking now fam
what's goody Andrew
as we say here
good to see you again Andrew
foreign
nice
Rudy sharing his contact info as well
for anyone out there
in Hawaii
my buddy tamula
out there in Hawaii just sold out the
blaisdail center like four shows in a
row or something he did a
crazy running shows there document the
whole thing very cool he's been on the
Pod as well if y'all
are interested in checking that out
one of these young Comics who blew up on
social media and is now selling out
everywhere
foreign
tips on setting up Mr X that don't seem
too forced
and don't seem too forced do you have an
example
trying to think of what what you mean by
don't seem too forced
foreign
get these lights going a little bit
Yoshi is restarting his computer right
now
for those of you curious
foreign
hilarious Joe said no Yoda jokes for you
I'll take that one the force jokes I'll
take that yeah yeah yeah I'll take that
one I don't hate that
one's hang up Mr X that don't seem too
forced what's the joke say
like the one I did about taking hits
drugs that don't seem too forced
I want to make sure I answer your
question
and thank you Mary for the shout out on
LinkedIn
with your boy post it on LinkedIn
I'm a good fit for people's holiday
parties and stuff yes I am
open and willing and ready and excited
to perform for anyone out there who has
a holiday party there
looking to do this year or just um
an event you have coming up you would
like um
a funny MC or you'd like a comedian to
join I'll let you Biz away
wordplay Mr X
like hits drugs and hitses and punches
yeah yeah so I don't think that sounds
forced say
I don't think I don't think there's
anything forced about that kind of joke
I mean that's part of Joe crying in a
misdirect is
something that can be interpreted in two
ways so the word hit can be interpreted
as hitting drugs or it can be physically
hitting someone
see I don't think that's forced
no I think that works as a as a joke
you just want to make sure that whatever
jokes you do that they're original
that's the big thing I think that's when
it can come off as forced
or whatnot if it um
if it's like a joke you could you read
on Reddit
or if it's a joke that you
um you would read on like a fortune
cookie or a Snapple cap or something you
want to make sure it's Unique to you so
you want to make sure whatever the joke
is
that it's personal to you and your
experiences
and your opinions or your points of view
and it's it's uniquely your sense of
humor and not something
that could really be just
regurgitated somewhere else
like a something I like to put my jokes
through is it's like
could someone else
could someone else say this joke and it
be just as funny
I always like to put my jokes through
that filter so the same thing for you
there say
um
that's a good way to avoid the forced
element you're talking about is it's
like is this something anyone could say
or is this something unique to me in my
point of view and my sense of humor
just ask yourself that question will
help you to overcome those kind of
doubts and struggles
foreign
yeah I'm back ah my computer is
restarting can you hear me your
computer's restarting yeah and it took
forever
this looks like iPhone versus Android
right
[Laughter]
[Music]
nope it doesn't do it
go over here trying to blow on it
let me see if I can do it like a
Nintendo cartridge yeah right just reset
hilarious
no worries fam
we appreciate you joining us yeah man
wherever the dial-up internet takes you
nice
oh we got our first joke posted from Jr
okay oh car
oh my God say said filmed on a ring
doorbell
[Laughter]
is hilarious
I was trying to update the quality of
this piece
[Music]
okay we got Riley all right we got some
jokes rolling in now we got some jokes
rolling in now
uh did you talk about Gallagher
no I haven't done anything oh okay
ah
well R.I.P Gallagher
yeah that's facts
yeah man
it's true
probably the first person I ever saw do
physical comedy like that with props
like I think I knew Gallagher before I
knew Carrot Top for sure oh yeah yeah
yeah for sure yeah me too
I don't even think I um
it was weird I hadn't thought about
Gallagher in so long and then when he
died unfortunately that's when you start
to sometimes that's when people start to
be remembered again yeah
um and then I remembered like he him it
was him and Sinbad where the first
people I saw on TV those are the first
Comics I saw on TV
and wow what stuck out to me with both
of them is how much fun
that they were having yeah like on stage
both of them are so good at just having
fun on stage
yeah
that's a good point
but yeah it's
I guess he was 76 years old yeah
did we lose me are you gone oh we did
lose oh there you are
all right Peter Yoshi's live stream
that's what we should be saying
somebody say a tragic watermelon
accident yeah Joe did it's hilarious
that's what I was trying I don't I don't
even know what the cause was
it's saying um yeah he's had several
heart attacks
yeah that's no bueno
um
I don't know
that's that's a good thing
that you don't know that we don't oh
yeah
um
I don't know I just saw the headline I
was like dang
another one
I know that made me I've been
um because I was supposed to interview
uh Sinbad before he had a stroke
so I've been in like I've been in the
DMS with his son because he was the one
helping
coordinate everything
and um he said he's still recovering
like I guess he's getting better but it
that's about as far as it's gotten
yeah like I don't know how bad it got
with him you know
but he's one of those that it's like
I mean that's my that's my guy Sinbad is
so he's one of those is like when
Gallagher passed and I was remembering
he was the first I saw on stage
I was like dang I don't want this to
happen with Sinbad to where it's like oh
man
should have uh gotten his flowers
yeah for sure you know
foreign
I hope not I don't want to be I don't
want it yeah
so we'll see
said he died on stage is that true
no
[Laughter]
I think Sage thinking of his set last
night I think that's what say is
thinking of
hilarious
[Laughter]
that's funny
well this headline says cause of death
explained but then
it didn't explain it aren't those the
best yeah just click mate
[Laughter]
but I did go back and watch some of his
stuff
and it's just he's just such a silly
goose very silly goose
but he had jokes yeah yeah yeah for sure
like solid written out like just very
solid jokes it just happened to be a lot
of watermelon smashing with it yep that
happened to be in there
[Laughter]
freaking failure is what it says
while in hospice care
that's what Yahoo says
yeah
it's hard it's hard out in the in these
comedy streets
[Music]
yeah dang I hate to hear that
yeah
how old was he
is 76
do you ever hear age and then think huh
that's pretty solid like you lived a
pretty good life
like 76 that's a pretty
pretty extended life yeah especially for
like how many uh like how much health
issues he had anyway
is what it was sounding like
sound like he had a lot he had several
heart attacks and stuff
yeah
an average life expectancy in the U.S is
77 so
oh really
all right
thank you
all right all right
cool all right
hilarious immedi says thanks for
bringing The Showdown guys I want some
laughs
I know it's like we brought that topic
up and then are both like trying to
multitask while
talking about it dude it's like a half
it's like a half thought out
half-hearted disguise I think I was just
waiting for more jokes to come in
oh yeah yeah we're yeah we're good we're
good we're still floating around 20
peeps right now so that that's I mean I
tell you for like for not ever promoting
this I think we have a great turnout oh
yeah this is you know this is the core
yeah these are the peoples for sure
agreed
um
good
yeah so we're doing joke feedback today
my friend so do post your jokes
we gonna turn up on them
turn up turn up turn up turn up turn up
turn up turn up turn
it turn up turn up turn up turn up turn
up turn up turn up
tiring up
turnip greens
did you do any other shows this weekend
uh
did you do any shows this weekend
I did your show this weekend yeah
outside of that
Lord I don't remember
um
uh so probably no
Yoshi
no
all right no
but I booked a corporate gig in
Charlotte
yay all right all right all right all
right uh I have a few leads on a few
others nice
um
uh and then I I'm doing the show in
Tucker this Saturday I'm gonna be in
town
oh are you okay yeah so I'm gonna go um
I went ahead and booked it with like a
few other peeps
okay um they're doing like a November
Fest celebration so there may be a lot
of people so we're gonna try to go scoop
that up
[Laughter]
all right
I was like oh there may be a little
little come up there okay let's see
let's see what's popping
cool
um
yeah I thought I was going to be out of
town and then
we were and then my wife informed me
yesterday that we were not anymore
hey that's the best you know when you
make plans cancel those plans especially
the plans that involve other people yes
for sure
all right
um
say asked okay we got jokes coming in
now okay we got several being posted
yeah poster jokes here
in the live chat we're going to give you
feedback on them
uh yeah
that's that's our new names apple and
Apple and Android yes this is this this
is a visual representation of white
privilege right here this is the camera
hilarious which is funny because Yoshi
is actually the successful one of this
um
Yoshi spends his mind his money
elsewhere I guess like on his family
[Laughter]
yeah if you saw this setup you'd be like
uh how did you not figure this out but I
am able to like figure it out all week
because I've been I don't want to like
demean it but I've been single dad in it
so I haven't been able to focus on like
any camera stuff and I just got this
camera like a couple weeks ago but I
haven't like
it's a it's a Lumix
oh you got a new cam like a new camera
camera
yeah like a new camera yeah yeah oh
because like that
uh no I needed something so I can record
longer sets my other camera only had a
20 minute limit but all my sets I mean a
lot of my sets were getting into the 30
35. so I'm like uh you know you know 45
you know what I'm saying you know
oh
gang gang
just a little Flex on it you know happy
we will be a headlining now
yeah
we've been doing time now sorry
what what'd you get you got a Lumix
I just got a mix like an old school one
that I can just like it's like a 4D or
whatever uh
and yeah just like something that
doesn't have like a limit on the
recording and then
um I didn't spend a lot on it so it's
like an older model but I hadn't set it
up with like the new this new setup yet
which was my goal but
oh no worries so yeah it'll be higher
quality like video yeah yeah
and um
but I think I think the video quality is
a good reflection of the quality of the
live stream so far
any new people we may have had in this
one are like all right
deuces
for sure I know Iowa I know I am
you're going to leave live stream
[Laughter]
I know I'm like oh
let me see oh there it is okay cool
so let's get some jokes going here go
they asked how do you get over a fear of
bombing
um
you just do it often enough it doesn't
feel
it doesn't hurt anymore you know what I
mean uh I think bomb I think you have to
just accept bombing as part of the
creative process
and uh
once you know
once you bomb it's about that recovery
time after the bomb and what you do
based on the bomb if you bomb and then
be like I'm not gonna write or don't try
to improve now you've let the bomb
win if you bomb and black all right I'm
gonna hear what was happening figure out
what I can do better and then go back
out and try to do it again and then even
if you bomb a second time there's a
thing you bomb enough times you won't be
bombing any longer
it's really that simple I know people
that I've seen bomb for a long time
and then over like the years and a
couple of more times being on stage
never saw them bomb ever again
yeah bombing is an eye of the beholder
you know it sometimes you know so I've
seen some Comics bomb and then they get
all flexing like yeah y'all see that
we're like well we didn't hear it but we
definitely saw it
um
but I think it does come down to just
repetition I mean the more you get on
stage it's just the more comfortable
you're gonna be you know and once you
have
more comfort and confidence in your
material
the less that fear of bombing will
appear
but I think yeah I mean I think
especially
I could ask so many questions that
aren't
and the answer is stage time like
like people are always looking for like
well what's the secret to do and I was
like well I've interviewed over 400
comedians
I've been a comedian over 12 years
it's getting on stage like you know what
I mean like yeah I'm almost wondering if
you can answer every question with more
stage time and then go into something
else yeah that's like the prep of us we
preface every answer with you gotta get
on stage you know
but see that's yes they said I've never
done stand up but once I told a joke to
someone I got no reaction I felt
terrible I can't imagine what it'd feel
like on stage oh it's gonna feel worse
[Laughter]
people are like that's the thing that
was just a one-to-one interaction
imagine happening in front of 20
strangers imagine having in front of a
hundred strangers oh it's it is it is a
death feeling in the pits of your
stomach like a good hearty bomb is like
just it gets all up in there
but then once you experience it you
realize oh it's not that bad
it's not that bad yeah and it's it's
you're it's just stage time like once
you're so once you get used to just
working your material
then the bombing is just a part of the
process
you understand I think it helps to also
understand that it everyone bombs and
everyone goes through struggling on
stage so yeah congrats you're a comedian
that's part of being a comedian is being
able to handle those moments and get
back up even if you don't feel like it
at the time
yeah good point but say hasn't been on
stage yet so it's like yeah you got to
get on stage
yeah yeah like the thing that you're
like afraid of at the moment of just
what happens if I bomb
yeah
you figure it out like that
once you go through it now you know what
happens when you bomb
and now you can figure out what you do
afterwards but yeah there's no amount of
lip service that we can pay to tell you
just get on stage the key to being
successful and stand up is stage time
and a lot of it and for someone who
hasn't gotten on stage yet how how would
you recommend someone goes about it
overcoming that fear
of not bombing well a lot of people a
lot of people listen to the podcast and
they've never been on stage but they
want to but yep there's X Y and Z
reasons why they haven't
for sure I think just preparation
like the more you prepare the more
you've gone in front of a mirror the
more you've practiced without a group
The more you've said your material to
yourself you know your material you know
what's like
I think that's what helps you
get over that fear if you've never been
on stage but if you're doing stand up
and you've not gone up yet
the work that you do before you actually
go up is just as important the feeling
of bombing obviously is a natural fear
that people aren't going to laugh at you
or people aren't going to
react and that's a part of the process
but if you prepare
before the time rather than you know and
you know there's there's a school of
thought that just that I've heard people
just say yo just go up there and just
stay stuff for five minutes as your
first open mic so then you know what the
feeling's like and then there's a school
of thought that says prepare as much as
possible whatever amount of hours before
you go up I'm probably more in the camp
of prepare as much as possible before
you go up mainly because I think
just going improv saying words and just
thinking that the stuff that's coming
out of your mouth is funny I've tried
that before and that felt terrible
yeah whereas when I when I prepared and
I bombed I didn't bomb all the way
through I bombed at stuff that people
just didn't like but there was just
there's some stuff that was funny
yeah my first time I had like a set and
I rehearsed it relentlessly and I think
what really helped me is I I booked a
date I think once I had a date on the
calendar that it it could be next week
it could be next month but it's like
once I had a date on the calendar then
it's like okay I now have accountability
that on this date I am going to perform
stand up for the first time so now I
need to do as much as possible to
prepare for that set and I think that's
what really helped is having that
deadline
yeah that's a good one I mean I think a
date gets you
a destination
and then if you're committed to it and
you're committed to that date then it's
just what you do beforehand but
definitely yeah I think you know
do yeah set a date I think that's a
that's a really good like just hearty
rule of just setting a goal and gonna go
out and meet that goal yeah so wherever
you are Google your city and like Open
Mic or Google your region or area and
open mic and this could be comedy open
mic this could be Music open mic it
could be poetry Open Mic I performed at
um karaoke before
um so just like Google a place where you
can go perform for your first time set
the date set the deadline and then just
prepare as much as possible write out a
set that you think is going to be good
yep rehearse it a lot
Go on stage and check it off your bucket
list
yeah
yeah first everybody said he prepped for
eight months before getting on stage
like you know so yeah I think I wrote
for a year before I got on stage
I wrote for a year and then took a class
and that's when I got on stage but I was
writing what I was interested like ah
maybe I should do this and the stuff I
was writing was like I had no structure
I didn't read anything I was just like
let me just write what I think is funny
and then once I got the class the class
is what helped me get more structure and
figure out joke structures
um and so that that's what helped me for
sure
Kaboom well I hope that helps there fam
hope that helps you there say and you
know we have classes to help you with
that structure of course at
hopperathmedia.com
no
[Music]
[Applause]
and a we're here for you as well
yeah put it back in here say well let's
see what it's like well let's see if we
can make your dreams come true
all right here we go all right
so
it's my favorite first
joke
up
oh and Victoria said try jokes on Tick
Tock practice on people naturally
just in conversation
I do that that's a really good way I
will practice premises on people just to
see their reaction
kaboom no
boom all right let's get into some joke
feedback at 5 40. 40 minutes into the
live stream I think it's time
for some joke feedback yeah
foreign
all right
we're doing it
uh let me scroll up we had a lot of a
lot of great comments you know and it's
great to see in the comments people
share in their own advice and tips and
points at you and I mean say was the one
that came up with filmed on a ring
doorbell that's pretty funny yo now
that's pretty solid yeah yeah that is
silent
yeah you got this fam where are you
based at say where are you um
see if we can get him let's see
because if you say Atlanta we're just
gonna come pick you up to an open mic
kidnap you
you gonna do these jokes
oh he's in the UK oh Harry Pike is in
the UK
we have several members of the hopper at
the verse in the UK oh yeah what part
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
all right oh here we go all right the
first joke I'm seeing
Jr I think right Jr yeah that's the one
I was seeing too
um all right I created a website for
people with attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder that was a
disaster I mean visitors to the site
seemed really excited but then they
totally lost interest
all right
let's make sure we get the timer
um
well just for I mean just for wording
sake I mean instead of saying attention
to attention I'm 280d to read it just
like create a website for people with
ADHD
that was a disaster
you don't need I mean in there
yeah visitors we're real excited
but then lost totally lost interest
okay
so I I'd probably say the thing about
this is
there's a premise that you make about
the attention deficit disorder
that we kind of see
but I guess the element of surprise that
they totally lost interest
kind of goes with the ADHD
like it just doesn't seem like a big
enough surprise
in terms of having ADHD
I mean I get it oh let's ring the bell
and you know what you know what's so
funny is like
we totally lost interest
[Laughter]
we we 100
got 80d on the 80d joke we were both
like uh all right
I started like playing around with like
the timer I was like is there an easier
way to set the timer icon hilarious
I was like is there a shortcut to sort
of click the timer every time
that's so funny
um
so yeah so first of all condensing it
but let's get Let's help people out
we've got a kid right
ADHD you could just put ADHD most people
know what that is so you don't have to
say all this stuff yes um
I I think
I just feel like you can just get to the
punch easier with less words I create a
website for people with ADHD it was a
disaster they totally lost interest
something like that or
um
the other thing is I do think maybe even
like coming back to yourself I created a
site so how did that make you feel it
would be better I think make it about
you rather than them
but it could be like he started the
website but then never finished it
because he's 80d you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah just thinking
like yeah what instead of it being a
disaster what's an example of it working
which is that it was a big hit
so I think I actually you know what I
don't hate this instead of being a
disaster
I think it should work and it could be
like and it was a big hit visitors were
showed up real excited but left early or
like
yeah so instead of being a disaster it's
actually success because add people
showed up and then this is what happened
yeah or add people showed up and then
they built their own website like they
got so excited like so it's almost like
they got 80d and then built their site
so it's like this cycle
that I created a website for people with
ADHD uh it had a lot of pop-up ads
yes
so they stayed yeah
yeah I like that
somebody put
say put got distracted by the ads click
here even that is very funny in the
sense of like it's it had pop-ups so now
I'm on Viagra
you mean like take the element of the
ADHD and go there
oh yeah people yeah Joe people
commenting Joe's punch up yeah someone
put a fidget spinner ad in the banner
mm-hmm
nice
oh yeah yeah Joe's Joe's is very clean
I think I st I tried to start a website
for people ADHD but I lost interest yeah
we've got distracted with the ads yeah
Victoria likes our punch-ups there thank
you Victoria
for sure all right all right
all right let's let's try not to get
ADHD on the rest of the dress yeah we're
let's we got a timer
easier way
we got a timer we're gonna stick to it
yeah yeah yeah
so here we go
Riley Galvin
I met a Defcon food master I could never
tell if he was making conversation or
going in for a throw punch
so here's the thing if he's deaf you
could still see him
but I think he's like it's like
basically like sign language was
confusing
okay so he's saying he couldn't tell if
he was talking or like trying to kill
him basically you know with sign
language
okay
I'm at a Kung Fu Master
but I wonder instead of I met maybe a
little more context
I learned karate from a deaf Kung Fu
Master
his conversations were deadly
yeah or he taught me how to have a
deadly conversation
yeah I punch after every sentence or or
something like punchlines
I learned comedy from a def Kung Fu
Master
and now I punch lines and he done yeah
yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I don't hate that I don't hate that
either
nice there you go Riley all right all
right we cooking we cooking shout how do
we cooking
foreign
next
next up we have
uh James
skeleton
uh
two-parter here oh boy most of the
two-parters but the second part's a tag
so maybe this will all encapsulate in
one
okay uh maybe
uh diamond mining is horrific
True Blood Money in that trade the only
place blood money is more horrific is
once a month at a brothel
at least diamond mining
the shovels don't sync up
at least with diamond mining the shovels
don't stink sink up
cool
[Laughter]
um
I I just need this personalized
like right now it's just kind of like a
generic statement
I need I need James in here somewhere
yeah
yes and just the reference of the only
blood money that's more horrific is once
a month out of brothel
It's just tough to say
yeah I mean I guess it feels like ugh
um it feels like you're trying too hard
that's what it comes off I think I think
basically this is like an example of
oh blood money could be interpreted in
two ways
so here it is and this is something I
think it was say that brought up
while you were um
fixing like your camera and stuff was
just about like he had a joke where hit
was interpreted as hitting hitting like
hitting drugs and then hitting someone
physically so I think
you can have a phrase that can be
interpreted in two different ways which
is a way to write jokes so I think this
is just an example of like oh blood
money could be seen as diamond or like
this brothel situation but yeah
I see where you're going with it James
but like
to do it on stage like I I don't see
this translating at all
yeah so think of ways I like where your
brain is at with thinking of how to
interpret something in two ways that's a
good joke writing technique so just
think of ways to do that but with
something that's more personal and true
to you
yeah and the the fear of that joke is
that you're punching down
and be careful about punching down
because as you punch down your audience
is very likely to turn on you when you
punch down on jokes
come off as gross in general in a way
like blood money and a brothel and
but I see where you're going with it so
so keep on keeping on
and anyone with uh joke ideas for each
other feel free to put them in um
the live chat as well feel free to help
each other out
and meet each other too hang out some I
know there's
several Comics around the world in here
so
you may have a neighbor on here I know
say is in the UK there's a few people
from the UK watching so I think he said
he's in the Manchester area
so if anyone's in the Manchester area
let's get let's get say on stage
uh
uh all right speaking of UK Harry Pike
Harry Potter Harry Pike
I work in sales my colleague is always
complaining that no one will buy from
him because he's a straight white male a
victim of can't sell culture
[Music]
um
or I can sales my colleague
trying to think if the pauses
straight white Mill a victim of
can't sell culture but I think one thing
is like
Harry I'm fairly certain as a straight
white male
correct me if I'm wrong Harry so I think
instead of you saying your colleague
just make it you
and then I like the word play on can't
sell culture i it translating the stage
is tough because they have to like see
it
almost or like
it may or may not
what what does that mean I don't know
what that is can't sell culture
it's a word play on cancel culture oh
okay
oh
okay I did not get that
so I think it would need to be spelled
out but I also just think he um
I think it being about him instead of
his colleague is funnier
gotcha
cool beans
foreign
yeah I hope that helps there Harry
so just make it about you and I think
it'll hit harder but that I I like the
writing of it though
um mudit
wait did we already read Moody no no
okay
swingers
uh growing up I thought getting laid off
meant getting laid my uncle once
confessed he got laid off and I said
congrats how'd it taste he paused and
replied
salty
oh my heavens
oh my Heavens okay okay mudit
seven John said Savage mudit
um it's like getting laid off and
getting laid my uncle once confessed he
got laid off and I said congrats how'd
it taste
he paused and replied salty
[Music]
so I I see the joke I actually think you
can simplify it without getting as
graphic yeah
because I actually think
even if you said he paused and rep like
I don't think you need that I think you
could just say my uncle once confessed
he got laid off he was very salty about
it or something of that nature like just
being salty
oh yeah yeah he was salty or something
about maybe losing his virginity
um like asking your uncle what it's like
to lose your virginity
um
yeah
yeah or even just yeah like he's
I mean I like I like
I like the Venn diagram that you did
there
but I
congrats how to tastes just feels like
I don't know yeah if even if someone was
getting laid I don't know if it would be
how does it taste how does it feel
yeah I think how does it feel or how was
it and then you can and then you can
make other references
oh it was pretty hard or it was rough or
it was salty now you're playing on the
emotional element consensual
yeah yeah oh no big deal it was
consensual sensual Resume Builder
yeah yeah I think there's more than just
like going straight to like the dirtiest
version of it
oh yeah how long did it last
that's another good one said say yeah
yeah yeah
yeah that's funny
um
um all right I think this is oh my
heavens
I think this is Victoria's yeah this is
Victoria's in our um can you just make
the whole thing take over our faces
yes there we go all right there you go
Victoria I was walking in NYC and a man
came up to me and said hey baby I want
to get with you I said excuse me I'm
married he said oh you can keep your
husband I just want to F you I said oh
my God thank you can you say that into
my phone I want my husband to hear it
then I gave him fifty dollars and said
now go and get yourself a good
get yourself good and sheltered
he said I'm not homeless I said you're
not homeless now that I gave you 50
bucks take it
take it to my husband take it my husband
worked hard for it
I need to not put my hands up in reading
class any longer because that was yeah I
think Victoria found a workaround she
realized on YouTube there's a character
limit but she learned on Facebook there
is not
um so I think she found a little work
around there
um
was walking in NYC came to me and said
hey baby I want to get with you I said
excuse me I'm married he said oh you can
keep
your husband
thank you can you say that into my phone
I want my husband to hear it then I gave
him fifty dollars and said now go and
get yourself good in shelter
the shelter
I think
the joke is
at the beginning
of like
came up to me and said hey baby I want
to get with you and I said excuse me I'm
married he said
oh you can keep your husband
I just want to F you
it's too many things
it's so many things
yeah
I don't know what the I guess what's the
premise
first off
yeah I think there's multiple premises
premise of husband hearing about this
there's a premise of the guy
been saying he's not homeless
uh I think there's just too many
premises so like that I think you just
gotta work in
and then this is like this back and
forth conversation I don't think helps
the joke
yeah can you say that in my phone I want
my husband to hear it then I gave him 50
dollars
homeless I said you're not homeless now
give you debugs
take take it my husband worked hard for
it
I think the joke is around a bad pickup
line or
maybe that she's married
she assumes everyone is hitting on her
when they're really not
um or if she gave him 50 bucks now he
can pay for the date
um yeah there's a bit of a turn going on
now we got a little Mr Rick cooking up
there
yeah this feels like a longer bit
versus just like one choke
so I think I said yeah it's two jokes I
perform but I combined it
okay
when I'm trying to get the premise of
the first part of the joke
yeah so yeah what are you trying to say
here Victoria
yeah I want the premises and then we can
kind of start to edit it but it's like
what are you trying to say
um
because right now it feels all over the
place because I think there isn't a
clear premise
to build on
phone I want my husband to hear it
yeah it really happened to me
she said I looked insulted but really
flattered okay so this really did happen
okay
I feel like that should come out into
the joke
this guy was hitting on me
I was insulted but flattered so I
recorded it or something of that nature
right recently got hit on by a homeless
guy
yeah
and gave him 50 bucks so he could pay
for the date
mm-hmm
I told my husband to watch out
um
if I wasn't married
I'd have a new home
or something like that
it's good to have options
sorry I guess Lance said I feel like
this joke was translated from English to
Arabic and then from Arabic to Google
translates English
[Laughter]
oh
hilarious that's so funny yeah I think
the confusion here is we just don't know
the premise so
um but it's it's great that it's a true
story
yeah that's fun but I think we may be
trying to over complicate it and trying
to over jokify it maybe just practice
just write it out as it happened and
then go back and see where the funny
parts are
did something happen
I said this joke was generated by AI
married by AI this is a deep fake
hilarious
oh yeah Tim said men don't care if
you're married guy cat called me I said
I don't want your husband I just want to
F you I gave him fifty dollars and said
I just want to fund you
[Laughter]
that's funny I like that because it
works on state it does well on stage
maybe it's a performance I believe it
could it could I could see an act out of
it working
because it's a conversation and then you
can act out what's happening that part I
can believe but I really do like that
Tim part about like I gave him money to
gofund
something like the use of gofund I think
would be funny
it was worth it for the insults okay
cool well I hope that helped
so I wish we could be more helpful
dreams come true yeah
sorry I hope that helped Victoria
oh yeah next time go fund yourself yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's a funny word play
yeah
all right
I don't know who read I read that one so
yeah exactly yeah you definitely did I
have to like I have to read three
balance that out
um
I cracked myself up I told my co-workers
I was down like four flat tires they
needed an explanation
I need a new job
so I think this needs context for why
you said it and then that may help to
explain
why you needed why you got fired
I'm down like four flat tires so like
where what kind of job would that not be
appropriate to say
like a mental health is it a mental
health joke
um
Down syndrome
I don't know why I left it that
I'm just trying to think of how it would
be like offensible enough to get fired
you know
yeah because that's what he's saying I
was down like four flat tires
does that mean you were deflated
yeah I don't
I don't get it
like I got the punchline of they needed
an explanation and I need a new job I
just don't get the context of what down
like four flat tires means
oh he works for AAA said say
I don't hate that
um yeah maybe more context what was the
conversation
that you said that joke that got you
fired or you that you said that and got
you fired
all right all right we gotta all right
[Music]
all right
all right here we go we're sticking to
the middle timer we're batting a
thousand here we go recently oh sorry
you go you got it yeah recently I hooked
up with a girl named latashay
choose exactly what you're thinking
Asian
oh you didn't know latoche is a common
name for girls in Thailand
or Leticia
all right recently I hooked up with a
girl named Leticia she was exactly what
you're thinking Asian
oh you didn't know Leticia is a common
name for girls in Thailand
the Asian and Leticia doesn't correlate
I almost think it has to be like
surprising like she's exactly what
you're thinking imaginary
like
yeah because even but the fact that it's
a common name for girls in Thailand
is more just a question and not really a
statement or a punch line
yeah that's what there's no punch line
here you're just giving us facts so we
need to misdirect which is like she's
exactly what you're thinking
disappointed so maybe she's disappointed
that
um you couldn't pronounce her name maybe
that's a tag yeah
um
but yeah I like the first one she's
exactly what you're thinking imaginary
yeah yeah
thanks Tim
thanks for sharing buddy Lance
oh oh
uh I was at this party
that had the best blue punch in the
world why I poured myself another cup
someone knocked on the door and said
are you done with the porta potty bro
that's pretty disgusting but very funny
I was at this party that had the
basketball punch in the world
I mean I don't
the misdirect is there
it's it's there
yes
um
I don't hate it I think what I'm trying
to trying to find a better
I think
the porta potty part is what threw me
off
um
well because it has blue water
oh uh so people would need to understand
that
yeah so what if is there another place
that has blue water
um
best blue punch in the world pour myself
another cup someone knocked under her
said I don't yeah you need to know a
porta potty has blue water
um
and if you don't or if there's another
example of somewhere that has blue
liquid anti-freeze
um yeah
the anti-freeze but for the for the sake
of the joke I get where you're going
there Lance
yeah
he said yeah I thought it was a stretch
you know what's so funny is like we take
all of these jokes so seriously and I
think half the people are just posting
it just to like hear their name and
they're like I don't even really care
about this joke
and we're in here like all right let's
see how we can really yeah how can we
bring this in
that's true that is true
um
next joke
scrolling scrolling scrolling
oh here we go Chris James
did you read the last one I think so
um Six Flags is opening a Psychiatry
theme park called red flags
there's the two rights the emotional
roller coaster and the mood swings they
constantly break down must cry this much
to ride this ride
I like that that's very cool I think you
can just separate it out I I think just
the line of
Six Flags is opening a Psychiatry theme
park called red flags that's funny
there's a popular ride called the
emotional roller coaster
uh like that's just funny and then my
sister gets on this ride called the mood
swings
and then it constantly breaks down and
there's another ride where you have to
cry this much and then almost do a
visual like you have to cry this much to
ride the ride or something like
yeah I don't even know if you need the
mood swings and I think it could be
personalized that like Six Flags is
opening a Psychiatry theme park called
red flags my favorite ride is the
emotional roller coaster
yeah but it constantly breaks down
[Laughter]
so then I end up on the mood swings
oh yeah yeah where you must cry this
much to ride this ride or something yeah
somebody said it spirals down oh yeah
yeah yeah
foreign
I like that
that's funny that's very solid yeah oh
yeah and some good tags coming in on
there that one as well nicely done there
Chris my girlfriend got the season pass
oh yeah John said that one nice
hilarious
that's great yeah a lot of good tags
coming in
uh John Mondragon
um is this I don't know sure it's mine
okay
[Laughter]
um cuffing season of daylight savings
start the same day because it's darker
out and you can't see they are ugly
okay
all right yeah
I don't hate it no I don't I don't hate
it
I think there's a pause
um
I think to tighten it up it could be
coming season of daylight savings start
the same day because it's too dark to
see pause they are ugly
yeah
and it could be
um I think you could personalize it
maybe my favorite two seasons are
cuffing season and daylight savings
because they start on the same day and
it's too dark
to see I'm ugly
yeah or it's too dark to see pause I'm
ugly
yes I think putting it back on yourself
is a better
joke
Jody Carter asked what cuffing season
was
[Laughter]
oh yeah
us us married Folk
uh cuffing season
uh is the season when people want to be
hugged up because it's too cold outside
so uh people describe it as when people
want to try to get in a relationship so
they have a partner to hibernate with
hibernate yeah
it's a good way to put it Asian season
that's the technical term
[Laughter]
coming to the end here
Shane
Cafferty all right I'm a hypochondriac
so moving to La has been a big
adjustment everything is dirty here even
the mosquitoes have
soot
absolutely
yeah I would have to be like mosquitoes
have covered or something like more
um obvious and topical
is hypochondriac means
that you are
always like
sick right or it oh you always think
you're sick you always think you're sick
okay so it doesn't really correlate with
mosquitoes
yeah it's more about
you being the one who thinks you're
always sick
so it sucks being a hypochondriac living
in LA
then there could be a commentary about
La everyone's so
fake or vanity
um I'm sick of living here perhaps
maybe there's something there
yeah or I constantly the butt
adjustments make me sick or the
facelifts make me sick or like
um
yeah something about something vanity
wise oh the only thing Faker than the
people are my ailments
thank you thank you
you're welcome
that was worth it right there
these kids just don't even what's so
funny
foreign
it's not even worth saying anymore but
they just I mean the 22 people on the
live stream get it but it's like dude in
like five years they're gonna be like
they were doing what
these guys were doing what for free
for how long
for
how often
but you know the people watching right
now get it and we appreciate y'all so
that's all that matters
uh but for real for real
hey
[Laughter]
feedback season baby
that's what we're in
feedback season
feedback secrets
oh that's perfect
amen amen
[Laughter]
um
all right Jerry Kroll
uh I gave up acting when I turned down
for the role of dead body number two
foreign
I gave up acting when I got turned down
for the role of dead body 2.
I think it would be almost be funnier if
you got accepted as that role
so then maybe that's when you knew you
should
quit acting when like the only role you
could book was dead body number two so
maybe I quit acting
when the only role I could book was dead
body number two
yeah or like dead actor number two
dead weight
yeah dead weight dead career
[Laughter]
oh and then Jody has a good tag they
said my acting was too flat that's
pretty funny yeah
yeah this has you could put a lot of
tags in there that's funny when I sit
down there Jerry
oh it's Akuma said I'll pay to see Joel
do the shoulder Lean by Young Dro
it ain't right two step and let you show
the lane dude
my roommate freshman year of college
failed out but he missed he missed every
he always missed class he never went to
class and his alarm was that song
so it would constantly go off all the
time so that's why I really know that
song so well on top of just being white
boy Joe
[Music]
hilarious young drizzle
Young Dro
um
uh
[Music]
I just want people to
I get it right two stepping
I just want people to hear that song in
case they hadn't if there's a way to oh
no oh no that's not the way to do it for
sure
that certainly wasn't it
I thought there'd be a way to do
picture-in-picture oh it only does it
with us
yeah oh never mind
it's all good I have to do it you're
like all right dude let's get out of
here what are you doing you're now
you're now you want to get
fancy Tech at the 90 minute Mark now you
want to start bringing in all this
you got you guys get it shoulder lean
yeah you want to do a pop-up we're the
ones with that PhD yeah exactly
I love that's the joke we started with
[Laughter]
and we were 280d
um idiot on the comedy circuit here we
go all right my sister's gaydar is weird
I told her my star sign was Libra and
she said I was gay because I was male
and believed in astrology
so there's no real
misdirect I guess
yeah there's no real misdirect
looks like he rewrote it I think it's
basically the same thing though
um but my sister's Gator is weird I told
her my
star sign was Libra
she said that made me gay because I'm a
guy who believes in astrology
I think maybe it's I told her my star
sign was Libra she said my star sign was
gay
because I'm a guy who believes in
astrology so now there's like a punch
line and a tag there
that's a much cleaner joke yeah
yeah you're welcome
[Laughter]
now we now we just out here in the
fourth quarter we just trying to Kobe on
them real quick we probably put up 84 in
the fourth quarter knocking them out the
part just all right enough joking around
with these alley-oops yeah go ahead give
me a joke
are we calling jokes from the bench yeah
bring them in here bring them in here
bring them out bring them out it's hard
to yeah with the punchline your mouth oh
snap
um
where's the next joke
it's a Jody or somebody else
is that much later
um
uh I think
Joe chihadic this is my first open mic
I'm like a virgin if this mic were any
bigger I would have to drink lots of
cranberry juice
oh it's an old joke he wrote okay it's
an old one
maybe he's not doing anymore
he said he said weirdly accurate
yeah I mean that's that's a pretty
played out premise of like
oh comedy is like losing your virginity
I hope I last longer than five minutes
or whatever you know like that's a
fairly common premise for like newer
Comics to like open up with yes um
so many times yeah yeah yeah
so just a heads up for anyone out there
like that's that's a very common and you
know
it's because it's an obvious premise
that you can get punch lines out of so
there's nothing wrong I'm just saying
we're trying to help people create
original materials so
let's keep that an old one Jody said
everyone's first joke is about sex
versus comedy you're right yeah it is
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
it's true it's a rite of passage I guess
yeah
and I think we're coming to the end here
um
it's a Jody's
oh yeah I think so
this one's yours uh I was watching porn
with my girl oh you
oh
I'm watching
say it with your chest yeah
oh my Heavens I was watching porn with
my grandma
I didn't know she was into
this is better it keeps getting worse
I was watching for my grandma I didn't
know she was into bestiality or that she
actually recorded a session
but she was really proud of her starring
role
Lord why do we do this
for this moment right here
I
thought
but for joke's sake
I don't think you need all the
bestiality and whatnot I think it could
be
I was watching porn with my grandma she
was really proud of her starring role
like
I think it could just be that
if I mean if you're gonna do this joke
at all which I highly recommend against
I highly advise against
but
um
I don't think you need all that filler
in between that's all fluff as they use
in the porn industry that's a lot of
fluff
get to the meat and potatoes Jody
[Music]
get to the meat shouter
[Laughter]
hilarious
cool
oh
ADHD grandma porn yeah that's a full
buttered ass kind of Life yeah if the
porn was called buttered ass I that's
all that's missing
[Laughter]
oh
hilarious
oh well I I hate that we're ending on
that one
but
we're ending on that one
[Laughter]
the comments are just amazing
yeah we roll deep out here yeah people
really get into it
all right
[Laughter]
gotta go I go cleanse my palate I gotta
go pray
I don't have to do 50 Hail Marys
you have to do more than that yeah Lord
all right
we did do it yep thank you Android
Android and Apple coming together we did
it anyway look at us this camera looks
just as good as your other cameras have
been though so it's like
honestly like it really isn't that
different so
[Laughter]
cool beans well thank everyone for
hanging out
the fact that we get over 20 people in
here on a weekly basis and don't promote
it I think that's amazing yeah
yeah they know we're here they know we
almost need a soundboard of just hip-hop
stuff
yeah we need like a A hip-hop sound
board
[Music]
all right
we'll go full with the old days
yay
thank you all so much for hanging out we
do this every Tuesday
I'll be back tomorrow at 10 A.M on this
channel
doing the right 10 Club but
you ready get out of here Yoshi let's do
it
all right y'all else have a good day out
there we love you